Hello.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
This is Math Stream, 1.1,
our first math stream.
And we're really lucky today to be able
to have some time with Shannon Dobson.
And we're going to be talking about
emergent time and chromatic types
and hear a lot more on this topic
and also check in with everyone's
questions that are in the live chat
or in the comments later.
But first of all,
just quickly introduce yourself
and then hear a presentation
and then have a discussion.
So again, I'm Daniel
and I'm here with my co organizer, Sarah.
So maybe Sarah, say hi
and then pass it off Hey.
Sarah calling in from Lockdown Forever
Berlin, Germany, and
I'm looking forward to talking to
Sheena Dobson
and who we are.
Thank you.
Thank you for a nice intro.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Shana, and I am
I'll be a graduate student in the fall,
but I've started a whole bunch of stuff
in the middle,
and I'm kind of a, I guess, a polymath
that got a bunch of degrees at once
and did a master's.
And I'm a I was hired right away as
a full time lecturer, kind of everywhere.
And then a couple topics
and I'm pretty interested in.
So let's see if if this can be exciting
for someone like Shayna.
I'm sure your attention
OK. Daniel, can you see this?
OK? Yep.
All right.
Am I ready to go?
OK, good.
All right.
So I want to talk about emergent time
and chromatic types and maybe
I mean, it's up to you all
if you want to ask me questions as I go
or maybe hold them
because I'm trying to concentrate.
What's going on here?
You're going to see there's some heavy
topics involved, but I tried to make them
as beautiful and palatable as I can,
so let's just get right to it.
What are these
and what am I talking about?
So I have a few questions
kind of driving this independent
of the mathematics.
I'm trying to make this
not super math focused.
I was trying to make those kind
of more applicable to everyone
because the math that I do is super
niche,
and I was trying to not do that
and be like non-inclusive.
So the big questions are philosophy.
Questions
that are driving me is What is time?
Is there anything that isn't time?
Time is always modeled as either
just like a Geiger counter
or it's this sort of accepted
background phenomena.
And I don't really agree with that.
I feel like
we haven't focused too much on it.
People think like, where is it?
You know,
I ask like sometimes I give talks and my,
my first question is like,
where is yesterday?
And of course, people like what?
You know, you could zoom out
and look at like the light,
you know, the light cone data
and things like that.
But it's like phenomenological,
really interesting.
Where is it and will it always be here?
And I remember
I was talking to Rafael before, so
and he's got this great paper about like,
you know, I mean, is it
we would always be here
and maybe it's not.
Maybe it's sort of
just maybe it came at some point as well.
And so I think it's sort of emergent.
So not like wasn't always here.
And here is probably not the appropriate
word. You're going to see that.
I love language.
So again, I'm super polymath
and a lot of my math
papers are super math philosophy.
And so I think there's
a lot of problematic
terms that we need to actually go into.
And so I actually said,
where's not our comedian time?
You know, so none our comedian the
you know, the
to be our comedian
is to believe in Infinitesimals
that you can always have a number bigger
or lower
and quantum mechanics,
you really have a cutoff, right?
So if quantum mechanics does modeling,
you know, cutoffs as you know,
spatial cut outs is not our comedian,
why is time not also not our comedian?
So I'm very interested in that.
What would that actually look like?
And we go heavy into that so, you know,
Sarah, I have the air that's theory
DA in the French continental philosophy
saying that there's always a
there is an A mathematics.
We always go there exists, you know,
there exists an X such that whatever.
And so that's very powerful.
The existential quantifier.
Right. But and qualifier.
But I'm you know,
what are the conditions for existence?
This is something
Chris Fields and I are working on.
Like what are those
not just like metabolic conditions,
I mean, all of this, you know, so
I think the big bang is a real problem.
And like going into that, of course,
you have all these wild theories about,
well, you know, it's like a white
you know, like a white hole
that pass through something else
and all this kind of stuff.
But I'm really interested in like
what are the conditions
to even have existence, right?
So what what would the conditions
be to have a discretization of time
what does that even mean?
So what is entropy
and a temporal discretization?
So we have this very vague
notion of entropy.
And I agree with Max Tegmark that
there is no objective notion of entropy.
You're like, oh, well,
there's a local influx of energy here,
but you know, the environment
surrounding it, loss energy.
So there seems to be a calibration
there, you know.
So my whole point is to category
the stop mechanism, just like
Chris talked about in his last talk,
you know, biologically speaking,
like when to stop, like,
you know, cellular dividing.
The stop mechanism on the bio level is
very, very, very intricate in my opinion.
And so I'm wondering like,
how would you categorize by that,
I mean like using category theory?
So my whole vibe here
is to try to actually
upgrade the mathematics that's used
in modeling some of these things.
Again, my head is pretty abstract,
so I see things abstractly,
but I think it's a gift
because it's allowing me
to see connections in a nonlinear way.
So my brain is definitely nonlinear and
I try to use that in linear phenomena.
So I say, you know, how can we say,
you know, there exists a time asymmetry?
But he uses this like phrase, well,
when there is no objective
notion of entropy,
I think it's really, really tricky.
There's also no proven
structural causality.
All right.
And so you had this, you know, the light
cone, it's a little vague right?
There's some problems with g r there,
some problems with the formulation
of light cone and things like that.
Light cones wouldn't withstand
quantum mechanics and stuff like that.
So I firmly believe, you know,
just like Bertrand Russell,
that there is no structural causality
and it leads you into these great things
like last Thursday ism.
And, you know,
the world was made 5 minutes ago
and there's really no logical
impossibility in saying that.
So I have not seen
a structural causality.
And so again, Chris Fields
and I agree with this,
and that's why we're writing this stuff
number eight,
why are we actually experience memories?
This is actually
like why a lot of this is very again,
taken for granted.
And so I'm really interested in
like why that is cause people
say you have memories to prevent you
from falling off a cliff again,
like association and base Pavlovian,
you know, survival.
And that's not what I'm talking about.
Right.
I'm actually talking about like how
why do you experience them?
Somebody like me, like a total precog,
like I remember everything.
And sometimes I can get haunted
by thoughts like memories
that just come, come in and I know
there's a lot of people like that.
Maybe you're just taking a test
and these horrible memories
just fly in your head.
Or maybe they're really good memories,
but the experience of
that is very strange.
Nobody knows what a thought is. Right.
And I was there.
I think you asked and Sarah and Chris,
it's talk.
You know what?
What is a thought?
And I've I haven't heard anything
about what those are people.
Oh, quantum fluctuations
and things like this.
Yeah, but there's something else going on
because,
you know, for instance,
like the speech that I just said,
I read number eight 2 minutes ago
and so the speech is gone, right?
It dies, but something remains.
And so what is that?
It seems like there's a hologram,
a copy of everything that you say
that's actually stored in the brain.
And you're doing
some kind of recall with that.
But I don't understand
storage of everything is discrete.
And so that's why this is very complex
and very beautiful.
So I say, what are they like?
What is the fundamental unit of thought?
You know, Alan Watts is going to say so.
Oh, it's like existence
and I'm not really sure
what the bio people are going to say.
What is it?
You know,
what is not a thought, you know?
So for me, you're going to see that I'm
going to invoke this finite condition,
a finite set is a compact,
totally disconnected space.
It's, it's it's like a cantor set.
So I think that what's happening
is time is like a cantor set.
And somehow
you are recalling over a Cantor set.
What is a thought that no idea, right?
No idea
how we're even speaking to each other.
So I think we actually need to go over
what that is.
These are just the questions
having begun the talk, right?
So questions, too, right?
What is causality like?
What is it again, if I don't believe in
structure you know, oh, A came before B,
that's very reference frame dependent
and reference frames are flimsy.
Right.
And so I say, well, causality per him
and then I say, well,
what is a measurement
that's very tricky, right?
Of course, the quantum problem
and just measurement in general.
Yeah.
And I say, well, what is a reference
frame that's even worse.
You know, according to me, my world,
according to me and my who is me?
And so that's going to be tricky.
So Chris and I both agree, like
what is this personal identity over time?
And you've got big branches of philosophy
like paternalism and endurance,
as I'm trying to do,
trying to figure out what that is right.
Who is this right?
Is is me today the same as me yesterday?
Well, clearly not, because the cells
are doing a whole bunch of things right.
We don't have any of the same cells
that we used to have.
I mean, maybe it's the neuronal things,
but, you know, you have a boundary.
And so what's happened?
So, you know,
I don't understand what over time means.
I don't know how anyone can be over
anything.
So then, you know, Sarah,
it wasn't you know,
shouldn't you talk about space time?
And I'm like, that's just a manifold.
It's like one of the most basic
structures in mathematics.
And we have more sophisticated
mathematics.
So I don't really vibe
with the manifold thought.
I think you can really,
really sparkle and dazzle
that up to see what's actually happening.
I don't know if you actually have
to unify them like that.
You could just be specializing time
instead of leaving time as it is.
So then I'm like, OK,
if you want to just use like
manifold and differential geometry,
you could also go number theory.
And so like
what would a number
theoretic time look like
and what would a number
theoretic space look like?
So you don't have to
just like my whole point is that physics,
like the framing of physics, is based
on the mathematics at the current time.
So a lot of quantum mechanics is like
linear algebra and operator theory,
but you could also up that
and make it like algebraic number theory
and then you'd get new physics.
So with me,
if you give new math, you get new physics
so upgrade the math, you know, so
what is the number theoretic black hole?
That sounds a lot cooler to me than the,
you know, the framing of the black hole.
The old model has a lot of problems.
Can you also, like, see me? OK, yep.
OK, cool.
All right.
So let's go through this outline
and again, I'll just keep the talk
at like an hour and then
all right.
So here we go.
So those are my like big questions,
kind of funneling everything.
So I'll talk about discrete time.
I'm going to really firmly say
that there is no synchronous
reference, that everything
that's happening now already happened.
You do have like a lot of time
in the brain to process.
So there is nobody is experiencing
anything as it is and things like that.
Also going to say that there really is
no self reflexivity because I don't know
if that there's a self
and so Chris and I are trying to actually
formulate all this together, right?
So I really don't think there is
a production designer and Darren doesn't
with those two philosophies
that are trying to say that you exist
as a four dimensional being
and you kind of exist through time.
And I think there's some problems
with that.
So problems with current
ism are enduring.
Schism is like, Oh, I got cut
and I have a reaction later.
You know, those pieces of you
were supposed to be independent,
but they're not.
We're in touch with our pain.
But they would say that it's like
not so it's, it's a little tricky.
I think there is no personal identity
over time.
I have no idea how this is happening.
There's like a
reset happening every, every,
every
whatever
you may not want to say Planck time,
but if there's not personal identity
over time, there's definitely, you know,
so I think the memory, whatever
it is, has a singular support.
The support is the, the,
the the places
where function is not zero.
So if you only have singular support,
then that means you're not zero
on a singular set.
So it's actually again,
I'm trying to upgrade the mathematics
used in all of this to fractals
and Cantor sets things like that.
I'll introduce chromatic types
and chromatic types is going to be
this new spin that I'm working on
that's sort of paralleling
what's called a helmet Toby type
a new holographic principle
based on these diamonds
that I really like and emergent time.
OK, so for the why, how and to
what extent that I was asked
to kind of fill out and said why?
Because this day there does not exist
a coherent
formalism of emergent time
nor discretization of time.
Imagine there is no continuum, right?
That's a huge, huge segment.
What exists actually between
the discretization what is emergence?
How can we again are complexity
of class, complexity
class in the sense of Turing degrees.
That's what I'm referring to.
So not equivalence classes, Sarah,
but like the Turing degree equivalent
that you still have this like there is,
and that's the physics of time
equivalent of a meaningful president,
but it's absent of all
because it was string
because industry is like sophistry.
We have a we have lots of physics
sophistry and mathematical sophistry.
And I'm like,
can we actually try to figure out how
we can actually have existence
with this discretization of time
independent of any kind of conniving,
you know, so how well we're going to,
you know,
hopefully have a wonderful introduction
discretization mathematically
all of it is commensurate with it.
OK, so I'm into a lot of.
Metrics.
Where you can construct spaces
based on algebraic spaces.
So I'm going to
try to go really lightly through this
because this is pretty heavy,
but so you can quotient out a scheme
which is like a higher dimensional notion
of an algebraic variety by a Patel
equivalence relation pro it tells us
a certain topology, an equivalence
relation is going to be a gluing.
So you get this diamond,
which is a shiv on a category
and a category called Perfecto IT spaces.
So this diamond
has these quote impurities
which are these geometric points
I refer to.
So this is a notion from Peter Schlosser
and I really like the diamond idea.
And so what happens
is that you have this,
this geometric point, which is a more
ism of schemes and it's almost like
so it's sort of like this that there are
mathematical impurities in this object.
And so when you have a normal diamond
and you have different colors on it
that are reflections of the impurities,
but you don't ever actually see
the impurity itself, you just see
the reflections of the impurities.
And so you're never actually getting
the thing, you're actually only getting
shifted versions of a reflection that's
what I think is going on here, right?
So you have your,
you know, your interface and no one's
ever actually experiencing the thing,
just a pro finally many copies.
So you can,
you can pull this Marxism of scheme back,
which is a technological move.
Then you get this what's called a pro.
Finally, many copies of spots.
See, this is the attic spectrum
of an algebraically closed curve.
So you can make these products for C
cross s underline for s underline being a
pro finite set, which I described earlier
so you can get these awesome products.
And this is
this is the new model that I use to write
this cool paper with
my awesome colleague
Robert Kuttner about a new model
of consciousness where it's like,
OK, this is what's going on.
You know, you have pro finally
many copies of this of of perception.
It's you're not really perceiving so
but that's pretty deep.
That's the hardest
some of the hardest math on the planet.
It's like looking at sheaves
on a category so democratized time.
Right?
So something I came up with just a bit
ago is like,
you know, there really is
no you can't really say A equals B,
whatever you want to say that really
what you're saying is a equals
B up to some condition X where X is
what is called a homer tobi type.
So type theory is like pretty rampant
in the end, like lots of awesome models.
And so a homophobic type
is going to be like a it's an equivalent,
it's an equivalence based on homo topaz,
which are deformations
between two spaces.
So you can say a is equivalent to be
a criterion X is considered
Z to be really careful
with the statement equals.
Yeah, and so really we really only have
Intersubjective agreement
on certain metrics.
So I really think there is no equality
for anything.
You just have a bunch of agents
agreeing on these metrics, right?
The brilliant Don
Hoffmann has a bunch of work on that too.
And I was working in his research group
for a bit.
So, you know, I think that mentation
these biological processes is I
just give him
a talk on like
Mentation and a certain hematology type
that it actually works in discrete time.
So how are you actually going to do that?
How can you actually model memory
and biological functions
over a disparate times time
that looks like a bunch of dots.
So that looks like memory
of a singular support.
And you're going to have to
really figure out how you could get words
and things like that.
So what I'm going to do is like introduce
this paramedic types.
So again,
there's no personal identity over time.
I think you only have chromatic 2 hours
of localization.
I'll go over that.
But in your singular support, you're
doing what's called a localization.
Localization is a way of adding inverses.
And, you know,
for instance, the integers, right?
If you want to add
inverses to the integers, you need to get
something like the rational numbers.
So to add inverses as a way of making
a space more full, I'll say.
And then also you can take categories
which are morph isms
and you can make them morph isms.
Isomorphic
which means they're invertible.
So localization is very powerful.
So again,
there really is no personal identity.
There's only personal identity
up to time.
I also think, I don't know, time
may be just the up too condition
for you to exist.
You are in essence localizing
at each point of the singular supports,
and I think I wrote it.
Yeah, wrote a little paper about this
that should be out
in the Journal of Cognitive Science.
So hopefully it's there.
So it is this.
So how much tummy time does the top
a logical space regarded up to a week?
How much will be equivalence
OK, so it's
a top a logical space regarded up to
how you know, how you can actually
equate various objects in the space
and what's called an infinity group void.
You know, you can get an infinity group
where all the Morph isms
are actually
so all the maps are actually invertible.
So we call we cometary equivalence
and map between typological spaces
which induces isomorphism
on all the topic groups.
How much of your groups are encoding
the homophobe behavior?
And so, so that's in that book
that I recommended to you so groups.
So we're familiar with groups,
you know that you know where symmetries
relate an object to itself,
but a group void, you have symmetries
acting between more than one object
as you can see in this like this visual.
So I've got a,
B, C, D, these are multiple objects
and you have maps going everywhere.
So a group void is a category
where all the morph isms are isomorphism.
So if I have an Infinity group, it means
I have an infinite, infinite morph isms.
So infinite Isomorphism.
So the big idea for the chromatic type
is to actually
put a chromatic tower
over a temporal logic.
We're all familiar with temporal logic
and you're
going to see what I mean by this tower.
So I think you can actually create
chromatic types instead of a hematocrit
type.
So we're going to be interested
in creating these chromatic spaces
that have their own notion
of localization.
And then you can get a new idea of time.
So localizing a geometric comatose.
So again, I told you,
localization is a way of adding
inverses in category theory.
That means you want to make your maps
isomorphism.
So we say given a category C
and a Class W more prisms,
we see the localization CW inverse.
You can get a reflective localization.
What you do is you localize, which means
add inverses, you complete the space.
If that's the Koshy space,
if you want to get sequences to converge,
and then you take the inverse limit
which is gluing, you're going to see.
I do a lot of gluing.
So for a category categories,
collection of objects and more prisms
and you have an associativity condition
and an identity arrow.
So how much of this again are maps ways
to get ways to get objects
to be equivalents?
And there's all kinds of ways
that you can do that.
So I'm interested in something
on top of logical localization.
So this is another type
of chocolate localization.
So we see a type electrical localization
as a left exact localization.
And again, I'm going to go very gentle
with some of these definitions,
left exact localization of an affinity
one category.
So that's a category
with infinitely more presence
in the sense of passing
to what's called a reflective seven
for any one category ET a collection
morph isms that are mono morph isms.
So with the details are
of course they're important, but for
the full point is
that you have a reflective subcategory.
What's that reflective subcategory?
It's a full subcategory
such that the objects
in the more bosoms
have reflections in the category.
So that's very cool.
So the objects
and the more prisms have reflections.
Every object and D
looks at its own reflection
by a certain amorphous empty data TD
and the reflection of an object
see and see is actually equipped
with an isomorphism.
So that's great.
The inclusion creates all limits and
it has all cool limits which do admit.
So the to say that you have limits
and code limits means
that your categories sort of a very,
very nicely well behaved.
So this is very neat
that in the reflective subcategory
it seems very apropos to pair
that with the diamond work that
I'm trying to do because
the diamond is dealing with
finite limit copies of these reflections
and the reflective sub category
contains
reflections of the actual objects.
It's a very, very special
subcategory.
So again, the whole idea is to get OK,
so maybe at every moment
you are actually top
a logically localizing
and so that actually means
you're actually
just looking at your own reflections
all the time, which you are, right?
There's a lot of maxim
that say, you know, you see what you are.
Absolutely.
So I still, you know, so I'm using
all of that beautiful mathematics
to actually justify a statement
that would only be like
without the mathematics, the statement
would just be like a sentence.
And I can actually try to justify it
structurally.
So think you're actually localizing time
as these kinds of equivalences.
So they're really is no well-defined
notion a metric.
You really just have
it. Why?
Why are we working in topological spaces?
Because the metrics are very subjective.
And so you work topological or
you don't really have a notion of metric,
but you have a closeness condition.
So everyone works logically.
And I'm trying to categorical
by the notion of time and space
needs to throw it into a category theory.
Let's talk about its Morph isms
and how you localize it
and how you invert the Morph isms.
So you need to ask, huh?
You know, so topological spaces,
you have a technology on the space.
So here, right?
With like the diamond,
I put it, you know, like Peter
puts a sheath on a,
you know, in a category like OK,
so what are open sets and a category
that's actually not trivial, right?
Like so, you know, I say the construction
of the top logical localization seems
appropriately meta
in its construction of a reflection of
what is already profoundly many copies.
I say the word V stack.
It's a higher notion of a diamond.
And I'll go into that a little bit later
so the second metric question is
how would you actually put a topology
like on an infinity one.
Category.
That's hard, right?
You have to actually figure out
what the open steps are in a category.
Right?
And so basic points that topology
and like anything in hashrate
is going to go over, you know,
topological spaces and topologies.
But to actually get one on a category
that's not so easy.
So there is something called an infinity
one slight on an infinity one category.
It's the data encoding.
And if any one category of infinity one
sheaves, the sheaves see the pre sheaves
inside a certain category of pre sheaves.
So these are just like I said in Chris's
talk, these are like ways of monitoring
kind of local data around the space
she's attached to certain spaces.
And so we call a topology
on a category site so what's this
chromatic tower while the chromatic tower
looks like this.
So it's actually there's a whole bunch
of work on chromatic theory.
Just plug in. Listen, but what is that?
Right.
It's a way of identifying spaces
using these chromatic towers.
So given this in
this is a blue sphere localization
of what's called a Moravec theory.
So these theories are ways of looking
at isomorphism classes of vector bundles.
You have a wedge some there
and so this
localization gluing, right,
localization is adding inverses.
So given that we call that the hematocrit
limit over the chromatic tower.
So there's a tower of these things
called spectra,
which are objects
that behave like co homology.
Theories and cosmology
theories are exploring holes
in spaces and just kind of data.
Nice invariance about space because
you want to classify these spaces.
And so you have these towers
based on the levels of spectra
so this is this is what I
might say,
the mobilization of a spectrum.
It's that it's pretty detailed, but
we're saying like it's localized
with respect to a certain P.
And so without without like super.
Going into the details of that,
do you have towers of equivalencies
and so based on your layer,
based on where
you are on the chromatic tower,
is what you're going
is how you're going to be navigating
so that's memory space to me.
Recall memory space, it's all the same.
Navigating
your Turing degree is, is in a sense
a chromatic tower like this
that create a command type.
I'm going to make equivalences
based on the layers of this tower.
So for instance,
if you're on the top layer making a
an equivalence between the top layer
and you know, so replacing home an error
replacing but upgrading the home,
it will be type with chromatic type. OK,
so we say for memories
and computer ability.
I said again at that mentation talk
that I just gave not too long ago
at the biological conference,
what else besides computing might
be involved in biological mentality?
Right. I'm just going a little
phenomenological
so we can pull this together.
Well, you know, it's a it's a hematology
type that could be a chromatic type
it precedes by a weak
equivalencies at far exceeds.
There's a lot of like expander graphs
and graph theory that model it.
I just think it's insufficient
and I think that you can
get into these towers
and get a little more of what's going on.
So I also say memory precedes
like an almost apology.
That's a very strict word from
all things, what it means to be almost.
But we can say
that memory has a singular support,
like I told you, like a Cantor set,
and it's what's
called a descent condition in my opinion,
which is a gluing right?
So a memory is recall,
and it's putting everything together
so that you can actually localize
at the specific instant,
whatever that is.
So it behaves
more like a descent condition.
So again, a weak equivalence is a class
and morph isms in a specific category,
immutability, right?
So there's a bunch of stuff.
There was huge mess
or awesome in mystery conference
or program
during 2020 about the site ability
to find ability and computer ability.
So computer ability, right.
Is the ability to solve a problem
in an effective manner.
You've got
all these calculus is Turing computable
weaker
automate a stronger hyper computation.
I say you know
I think it's the actual ability to
to construct decent conditions.
So I think we need to take these
very strict terms
about how we navigate
and categorize them.
So you see me kind of adding like,
well why don't we upgrade
that, upgrade the mathematics, use their
defined abilities about structuring
knowledge and concept formation
decide ability say binary decision
problem is the side of there.
Is this an effective method
for deriving the correct answer?
You know,
and this it's very this is very kind of
clearly
not, you know, this is not what I
was giving you in the Chromatic Tower.
I think there's more ways
of getting around and saying
things are actually effective if you use
the sort of weak equivalence time.
So memory.
So what else besides information
algorithms are involved in biological
intel anyway? A lot.
You've got geometric logic, girdle,
incompleteness, angular support, right?
So I call this in my paper,
Robert, we come up with a nested
hierarchy of awarenesses
and I'll go over that
in about one second.
So I call it a one
to one awareness of capacity
to construct morph isms
between other one awarenesses.
So we're all relating consciousness.
Whatever
it is, is geometrical and relational.
I don't think it's that computational.
So you get this category
all I'm trying to figure out a way, oh,
we know the notion of Turing degrees,
let's
get a categorical notion of that. So
I say
recall your ability to recall
is what's called a localization sequence.
This is a whole fiber sequence
where you have these maps
and you have a condition between factors
and what pops out is a fiber.
And so you are given.
So this is what I think is happening
when you actually recall,
you look for a certain state out
pops a memory, right?
So there's a bunch of category theory
going on.
So one of the fundamental units of life,
that's very tricky, right?
There's a lot of I think there's a story
about like a beautiful monk
that went up to a hill
to just sort of self defecate
and everyone thought he passed away,
but maybe he had one heartbeat a year.
So my question is like, what?
What is that?
What are the fundamental units of life?
Could it be
that someone slips under the radar
of what we would call metabolic life?
But there's another set of brainwaves
that are maybe mirror
symmetries on the other side.
So like you see, I have this chromatic
tower with everything on the right side.
I want to build a
what's on the left side.
So all of this
I have chromatic towers with right sides.
Yeah.
So maybe this is the condition of life.
What if you reflected on the other side?
What does that even mean?
So again, I'm
playing around trying to figure out
levels of consciousness.
So for instance, Clive Waring,
the famous case, awesome pianist, right?
Super brilliant pianist,
got an HPV and got an H.
Mike got a retrograde amnesia,
and so he's got a seven second memory
and he only has motor memory
and no personal memory. Right?
So you can be like
he'll say,
I've never seen a doctor before
in my life,
and he's visited by doctors all the time.
So it's very interesting
with someone like that,
you have to ask the conditions
of what are Clive Waring's
fundamental units of life?
And I literally think you could
you can more easily categorize
what's going on rather than just saying
retrograde amnesia.
Maybe some layers and the tower layers
in the chromatic tower have been gone
and that's what's happening.
So layers in that chromatic tower cut,
then you actually have,
you know, so just like a geometric way
of interpreting all of this.
OK, so let's get to discrete time, right?
So a discrete time.
Why do we model
time is continuous. Like why
again, I think it's an overlook and
I don't think we haven't focused on it.
So why do we model time as a counter
or as the background for some kind of
background dependent model? Right.
What I have pictured here
is what's called a spectral sequence.
And so if time looks like
these series of dogs inside
the dog is encoded
a whole bunch of information about space,
so you can model
time is like a module in space.
And that's what I said
when Chris gave his talk right
so that points
there are not just points, right?
They actually encode other information,
but you can see that
there are gaps between points.
So if you model time is discontinuous
or, you know, or democratized,
what's actually in between the gaps.
So then we say, OK, well, quantum
mechanics model space is an honor
median field.
Why is time also not not our comedian?
Why not?
So I open with that question.
What would it mean to phenomenological?
We have a discrete time.
What would exist between like two,
one and 22?
That's really rich what's actually there?
Maybe Susskind would say
that's the pure emergence, right?
He's got the two black holes entangled.
He thinks emergence
comes from the entanglement black hole.
So everyone's looking at that
and then you get paternalism
and temporal parts again.
It tells you where you exist across time,
just like you exist across space.
So, you know, I asked,
why do we experience memory is more?
Is time entangled with memory?
Where does entanglement
end? That's my question.
How would memories
actually exist in discrete time?
That's tricky.
That's tricky, right?
So again, you have someone like me
who thinks
there is no personal identity over time,
but yet you have a memory, right?
Somehow.
So anyway, so
how would you actually define memories?
And in time, I don't think
there's just one timeline here.
So I put together this theory
where I think you have the
the levels of time you have is depending
on the levels of category that you are.
And so I'm going to go over that.
So going to levels of time
that you are able to navigate
depends on your complexity class
and the level of space
that you can actually navigate.
So how would we experience memories
in an end time?
Imagine you had in levels of time
in a tower
so with Roberts in our pluralist
minus paper and also the Perfecto
Diamond Paper, right, we say, you
know, awareness is a it's the I,
we can do it representational and say
it's a representation of a new non,
but we also want to throw consciousness
into levels and layers.
So right here
you have a basic notion of a one category
where I have objects
and I have morph isms between objects.
That's it.
So one category is it contains objects
and one more Fisman.
So just a quick category theory
like godmother is beautiful
and I cannot do it justice in 2 seconds,
but I'm given just a little recap
of what we need in the middle.
Here you see a two category
two category contains
objects, one morph isms
and what we call to morph ism.
So to morph isms or morph isms
between the morph isms.
You see,
I have a map here from F one to G two.
So this fit and you see,
I have a gamut here from F to to G one.
So that's
this is getting it what I think's right.
So basic basic complexity class can only.
Oh, hi, Daniel.
Hi, Sarah.
We have an interaction. That's it, right?
That's super precog.
Is there anyone with Total
Recall like me?
I can put a map between this interaction
and this interaction.
This is what I'm talking about.
A three category three category
looks like this.
You have objects,
you have morph isms between the objects.
You have morph isms
between the one morph isms.
And you have a three morph ism, which is
a morph ism between the two morph isms.
So you can see this
step two going this way.
All right,
so this is what I'm saying, right?
Depending on your level of category,
your level of awareness,
if you are a three awareness creature,
you're able to to navigate this way.
And so that's why I said so.
If you're a three awareness creature,
you live in three time.
If you're a one awareness creature,
you live in one time.
And again, I just I just went onto this
because people like me
are either haunted by sad memories
or blessed by amazing memories.
And time for me did not seem to go
linearly it goes like this.
So we have this
for subjective experience.
We have this nested categories
of representation.
You've got a one awareness,
you've got a two awareness.
So that means a category of categories
of representation.
Three awareness.
A category of category of categories
of representation in awareness is our top
A categories of categories of categories
so you can see that what what
what does this sort of correspond to
is like, well, me giving you this awesome
presentation and being welcome in
your environment and us also
being of the Cambridge Apostles
and having like t you know,
so not just being able to imagine
something like that,
but being able to partition your brain
and split your consciousness
and to actually be able to do that.
So I'm all I'm really excited about
splitting consciousness and trying to
physically be in multiple places
because I don't think I don't think
there's only one timeline here.
But to split consciousness,
you'd have to be able to do this
in the brain, you know,
which is cool.
So we come up with so along within time.
And so again,
you can see that with the mathematics,
you're able to do a lot of stuff here.
So within time I came up with this
and you know what I think according to
In Time, you have a finite language.
Like what is that?
Well, if you know any dairy, donkeys
or anything in his avatar, it's
going to show you that the got somatics
and the Glossiness, you know,
that you're
fundamental units of language.
If you open them up,
there's not a lot there.
But actually the process of reading
is a trace.
It's a wild phenomena because you're
pulling together so many pieces.
So we actually I came up with this
awesome language scheme that was like,
well, you know, and in the one space,
you just have your normal eye.
We me, my mine.
But in end two,
you'd have like a one eye, a two eyes.
This is if you're in two awareness,
right?
If you're in the two category,
then you would have actually like a
one eye to eye, a one me, a two me.
If you're in a three category,
you'd never one, I a two, I have three,
I a one me, a two me.
So instead of just she her,
there'd be like three she three her.
And I think that's the level of intricacy
in the new language.
So getting to some of the physics stuff
and going into the emergent time.
So I came up with this idea
for a perfecto
a dictionary again, perfect spaces.
Our Peter Saul says brilliant work
and I just think it's amazing.
And so I do think quantum physics
needs to be a little revolutionized
by replacing Hilbert space with the
perfected space replacing state vectors.
The geometric points
that I just gave this talk at
UCLA's Ipam Entropy Conference
not too long ago,
and I think it was pretty well received
replace the tensor product
with the diamond product based non
locality with finite lemony copies.
It's Farsi replace superposition with
these pro Patel sheaves and for a finite
set the collapse of the wave
function was such so tricky
replace it
with what's called a tilting operation,
which takes this from characteristic zero
to characteristic P and get this awesome
perfect modular curves.
Replace upgrade the holographic principle
with the six functor formalism,
which is a growth and deconstruction.
And I'm about to show you
that you can replace quantum topology
upgrade it with this it tell cosmology
replace operator out again.
It's great,
but you can just upgrade stuff.
So I shouldn't say replace the upgrade.
Let's let's let's let's replace
operator algebra
with a non Syrian version
and unitary with a certain descent data.
So you have this this is Peter's
six Functor formalism.
We're in a six functor formalism.
And as a way of making a theory,
I would say really it's,
it's a, a notion of replacing and point
a normal point, correct duality
with a billion sheep column ology and
it's something called verdure duality.
So there's dualities going on here,
which is why I thought it'd be great
to pair it with the holographic principle
because the holographic principle
is really fortified
by one melt is seen as a CFT
proposed duality between
the gravity duality.
So you have this form of case theory
saying that
I'm working on of a diamond
and you have these the six operations.
And so with these six operations,
these are just image factors
between sheaves and you get this notion,
this is what I'm thinking of.
So in quantum gravity, right
you have the holographic principle
and it's still
very kind of loosely defined
and it says
it's given and only a negative condition
defined by what it's not.
And so I, I think the holographic
principle, instead of having AIDS
anti disorder space in the middle
and the conformal field theory
in the bulk that you could actually have
the six functor formalism in the middle
and the proficiently in many copies
like the diamonds
looking like the conformal field theory.
This is what I'm working on right now.
So emergent time.
So these, these taxis
are higher dimensional diamonds.
And so they're certainly holographic
in a sense that they encode
already for finite many copies of data
that's already multiple on two fronts.
So a V stack is a two sheaves.
So this is like the shoes
that encode local data
so this now it's, it's,
it's one category up.
It takes values and categories
rather than sets.
So you're going to have to shift
to V stack if you want to do this poor
finite language.
So here's a conjecture with Chris and I,
you know, we're trying
to generalize the distinction
between separable and entangled.
This is not easy
so once again, recall that the geometric
points in the diamond amorphous
schemes, there's something called a bear.
Why is Seligman info morph ism?
And this is an ad joint pair.
And so
OK, so you have an Agilent pair,
there's a sort of like inverses,
like inverse functions,
but they're functions.
And so we extend this idea to the two
adjoining pairs.
This is F Upper Star,
R F Lower Star for the derived category
and then F lower shrink and F
upper Schrute shrink is a kind of slang
for the punctuation.
So those are referring to once again
the Peters operations.
So that's the grand correspondence,
right?
Is going to be this this derived
category, which consists precisely
of the hotel sheets of these certain
modules for a small diamond.
OK, so let's get to emergent times.
So what am I going to use all this?
How do I actually pull this together?
So if you consider the simplest case,
we say an event.
What is an event?
A, I'm going to call it a top
a logical localization
of any particular reference frame
event is normally like, I don't know,
simultaneity or something like that.
Try not to use the word slam alternates.
We'll say a top, a logical localization
of somebodys reference frame.
Let's consider that to be a point
in the diamond topological space.
On that point is a certain site
I told you right
this how you're going to get a topology
we're going to call this site
the pro hotel site, the category of pro
finite sets. S So this is from
more Peter's work on condensed
mathematics.
So global time emerges
as a set of continuous mounts
from all pro finite steps as the team.
So again, you have these chopped up
notions of time and you can get global
time to emerge
as the set of continuous maps from again
the all the pro finite cantore sent back
to t back to the top of logical space.
So all the time can be considered
as a sheaf of sets on this hotel site.
And that's called a condensed set
based on his work with the foursome
so emergent time results
in passing to the larger category
of shoes to consider a condensed
version of this is an F construction.
I don't want to go over it
too much at the moment.
So a second conjecture
a way to get an emergent time.
You can actually use diamonds
and take equivalence relations
of those to actually get the V stacks.
So again, when I showed you
the definition of Diamond,
you took equivalence relations of you
took protocol equivalence relations.
Well, it's upgrade
and you can take actually equivalence
relations of diamonds
to get modulus spaces of these stacks.
That's pretty big.
So there's new work being done about
how do you actually, you know,
how about a new algebra?
This is Peter and Dustin's new work.
How do you do algebra
and rings and modules carat topology.
I think this stuff is great
and this is where I'm at.
It's like, hey, we need to
rev up mathematics.
You need to upgrade a some physics stuff.
And I think we can all learn from it.
So if you can turn functional analysis
into a branch or community algebra,
that's very nice.
Build a version of algebraic geometry
allows rings
of Convergent
Power series is basic building blocks.
Because my question is
how do you actually do analysis
and non r comedian geometry, right?
That's actually kind of tricky
and exciting for a mathematician, right?
So you want to put some kind
of completeness condition on modules
which are like they mimic vector spaces,
but the scalars are not fields.
They can come from the rings,
the coefficient of the rings.
So in such a way that the free objects
behave like some kind of power
series instead
so you
can construct algebraic geometry,
you can start with in a boolean category
of groups, you have a tensor product,
which is just a way of organizing.
And then you can consider rings
in this sort of category.
You can associate spec
R with the same spar that I showed you
on the diamond and basics,
and open subsets can correspond
to localization so look how cool this is.
You're using Localizations to define
what an open subset is.
Include these figures together along
these open subsets.
You can form these schemes
and accordingly the category of R modules
values to form the category of quasi
coherent sheets.
So again,
this is all Peter's construction.
I think it's great.
How do you construct analytic geometry?
We'll do the same thing
but topological
building groups
don't form in a boolean category.
I will just go over this.
You can use the this notion
of condensed mathematics
to make it make things a little better.
You can replace topological groups
with these condensed sets.
So here's the whole point.
So this definition, right?
The hotel site of a point
is the category of finite set.
So these are counters ish
with finite and jointly subjective
families and maps as covers.
So we say a condensed set
is a sheaf of sets on the pro hotel site.
So again,
we're working pro finite and pro hotel
because of the diamond condition.
So similarly, a condensed group
ring,
whatever on the proton side is called
that you can put a category together
condensed and condensed objects.
So this means that
this whole thing is a functor.
So you can get a functor
from certain categories.
That's fine.
I don't want to go into this too,
too much.
So given a condensed set,
you can refer to two stars.
It's underlining set.
So there's a canonical example that illustrates how you would actually change two
from topological space.
So let TV a topological space to t
there's associated a condensed set t bar,
and that's defined by sending any
a finite set to the set of continuous
maps from S to T.
This satisfies both properties.
It means that for any map
for which the composite is continuous,
it's continuous
so t underline is a condensed
this finite set.
Yeah.
So y like, why are we using all this pro
finite condition?
Well,
because once again, it's in the language.
I don't want to get lost in the details.
So it's in the language, right?
It's in the awareness.
The level of awareness that you are right
dictates your whole complexity class.
So if and again, if these spaces are pro
finite spaces, right,
then you need to make sure that
what do we mean when we say localized?
We need to make sure we know
what the open subsets are.
And that's why I was using like the pro
hotel site there's that's just one idea.
There's lots of ideas.
So you could model this.
But the main takeaway
that I want to kind of leave
everybody with is like, OK,
so what are memories like?
There is no synchronous reference.
How are we actually getting through time?
Yeah, if every point is desperate times,
you must be getting through
time,
you know, through your localization.
But I'm trying to try to upgrade
the consciousness level and go, well,
you know,
I think you can actually upgrade
the level of awareness if you can start
thinking in terms of morph isms
and morph isms between morph isms. So
you get
the emergent time phenomena
by using the pro hotel
site, and then you get the diamond
holographic principle
by using the six operations and the four,
find out the minute copies like that
so once again,
you get the chromatic types
from looking at these towers of
localization, and you can put this over
a temporal logic to maybe to maybe,
you know, figure out what's going on
with like wiring once again,
like where is the meaning in that?
Yeah, OK.
So I put up some of my references
and I think I will just
stop there.
Right.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Maybe you can unshared
and then will be really happy
to ask you some questions for sure.
All right, Sarah, maybe take it away.
Yeah.
So so that was a great brain scramble.
Like, I guess I'm wondering, actually,
this really comes directly
from philosophy.
Before I went on this
livestream,
I was looking at just where topology
fits into the philosophy of the standard
Stanford Encyclopedia.
And one thing that stood out to me
was was mono logic.
And I found myself asking,
you know, with all of these new
topologies or set theory
or however you want to do it, like
we always kind of run into this tension
between
these really complicated
chromium morphic,
whatever kind of morphic
you know, our ability
to conceptualize these morph isms
and our ability to, like,
make use of them
or we make these really complicated
math constructs.
And then at some point
we have to communicate with each other.
And so I'm kind of wondering,
with any math construct,
it might maybe
even specifically yours, like
how do you see the construct converging,
like looping back,
you know, conceptually such
that it doesn't just run away from,
you know, from us
in our ability to understand.
Yeah.
So well, that's why I said so.
For me, thinking
like those constructs are not difficult.
I would say the communicating part
is the difficult part, you know,
like, I mean, you to watch children,
they're all over the place, right?
I think I think you are here to imagine
and then you actually I'm
like a super synesthete.
So for somebody like me, right?
I just rattled that off
and you saw that that was probably
the easiest thing for me.
But asking me to maybe replace
a cartridge in an ink like a printer,
that might be really difficult for me.
So it's interesting that when you say,
how do we not lose it?
So I think that's what I was saying.
I think it depends on
where your brain thrives.
Like somebody like me,
I love the thought of like, oh yeah, I'm
definitely a three awareness.
I want to think of that more prisms
between more prisms and more prisms.
And so I actually don't think
they're difficult.
I think, you know, it's
something like it's just it's just that
math is just another language, you know?
And if you're a person
that, like, likes learning new languages,
I think there is no difficulty around it.
And so I don't think for me, I don't
think there's anything hindering it
because I think what's worse
is to leave it in a word statement.
If you didn't have that math
justifying it, you would just
have a sentence saying.
What?
Like the. World is. Unknowable.
Or something like that. Right.
So I actually think you're just kind of
displacing, displacing,
you know, you're doing physics.
Physics is totally hard, right?
You don't know.
Like, OK, but let's say, for example,
because in motor logic,
they were just talking about
knowing versus assuming versus, you know,
so they have these kind of
conjunctive sections in a sentence.
And and I mean, I don't know,
I think language is actually
the hard thing and actually making math
book into language in such a way
that we can actually communicate
without exhausting each other.
You know, like actually make the make
the information transfer
is, you know, once
you go from like believing
to assuming you get all these funky like
predicates or
you get all these funky
like contingencies.
And so actually having math such,
you know, that
that works
with all of these subtleties is like,
I don't know.
Anyway, that's that's
where I'm coming from is like,
how do you get a map that doesn't
that doesn't get, like,
punked by language?
That's funny.
Yeah.
But isn't it exciting
because you didn't know much about
topology till I said it, right?
But you're on an exploration
and you're learning more so I don't think
it's actually detracting at all.
Right.
No, no. I'm not saying detracting.
I'm saying
facilitate help like compressing
and compressing language,
you know, compressing concepts.
Right.
And I think on my end, I'm not
I think that's might be deleterious.
I think it might be open them open
all the concepts what's you know,
I don't think time exists anyway.
So it's like, what's the rush right now?
I'm just like,
all right, now, you know what I mean?
And one note on
that is the linear strings
spoken or podcast
or live stream or text, right?
They're often ill specified,
but also it enforces a so-called
temporal structure, a local syntactic
and a semantic structure.
And whether one chooses to see these
these associations as foundational,
like the routes
that this is growing out of,
like the previous literature threads,
is it running off away into the dark
forest in literature, or is it actually
anchoring in vast bodies of knowledge?
So really interesting this discussion.
Oh, yeah. See, that's a dance.
OK, so how cool that what's natural
for me is like math and literary, right?
So you've got some heavy philosophers
that we're on to, some great things
and I'm like, hey,
why don't we just fortify
what they're saying with some diagrams?
And you see it's easy
if I say, oh, maybe five waring's
chromatic, two towers, cut
that in a certain way, like the math part
there is actually
while there is a steep learning curve
you're able to actually get inside of fly
wearing in a way that you're not in a way
that just like Daniel saying,
you know, retrograde amnesia. OK, great.
That's a linear word.
You need a sentence,
you actually need to go into that.
What is that?
And so I actually think
language is the key thing.
If it's actually to compress it
and if it's actually not transparent.
There's a beautiful transparency
in mathematics is all there, you know?
And again,
math is not perfect either. Right?
There's what is that point?
We have some serious problems.
You know, you've got
you've got predictive and then, you know,
how many definitions in math or self
referencing is horrible.
You know, so
like math is not to be worshiped at all.
And that's why it's like, oh,
we should just have all the languages.
You can see
I talk about everything at once
and I'm like,
that that's my synesthete, right?
I think there's actually
the beautiful thing about the synesthete
is that maybe you can see
like an aerial view of things.
And I think for me,
I can do a local global
just because of the way
my brain works, you know?
But then I was, you know,
I was trying because I love
everybody's like differences
and I don't want anybody to be like
anybody else.
And I was trying to say like, hmm,
it seems that, you know, maybe
sometimes we're one awarenesses
and sometimes we're one of awarenesses.
But I really I'm really interested in
why like, I don't know how you two are,
but if like if you have Total Recall
or memories, like,
have you ever had memories just come in
or future memories or deja vu?
I'm really interested in stuff like that.
Yeah.
I just wanted to clarify the,
the compression thing, though.
I want to defend compression
for a minute.
And normally I would agree,
you know, like the connotation
with that, I'm like, no, that's bad.
You throw away a lot of nice subtleties.
But I've definitely felt
in my limited experience with philosophy,
I've definitely bumped up against
some spots where there have been words
that, you know, somebody once
somebody gets it, what somebody
puts a noun to a concept to a word,
it's like this
fantastic compression algorithm
where it's like, Oh, that's a concept
somebody had and they put it into a word
and now I can pack it up
and like make some more space in my brain
for other stuff.
And I think that is like that practice,
whether it can be in math
or in words, like in whatever mean means
you do, it's, it's just it's the best.
So I'm always now I'm finding myself
like looking for that,
for that ratchet thing.
You would love
then you would love math, but it's like
because it's all symbols, right?
But I'm just saying, yeah, I don't see.
It compressing
doesn't at least not from my brain.
Like, I can't, I can't like
it doesn't package something up
so I can make more space
for other things.
But but it does because it's like, oh,
there's a tower.
So you
can just keep the tower in your brain
and not the 800 pages that go up there.
Just like when somebody puts a noun
on a concept like anti to sitter space,
I think.
Yeah.
I mean, for me it would be,
I would be deceiving myself to think I'm
just storing the word.
You're not, you're
storing all the physics and everything.
Know, what do you,
what do you think about that?
Right.
You know, this nesting is a topic
that comes up a lot.
So we talk about nested
Markov decision processes
how within the active inference model,
just only looking at the mathematics,
within this one little clade of math,
you can test those models.
But then there's also nesting.
That's based upon category theory,
not my area, but it seems like
there's very nuanced ways
of doing nesting and relationships.
And so what I heard with this discussion
around like a sort of a whole
total system
shift upgrade with a dictionary,
it's like Synergetic and Bucky Fuller
in that if you understand the interfaces
interfaces between what these things
are currently doing in the system,
you can take them out
and like hot swamp them.
It's like, OK, it's a graphics card,
we can make it a different graphics card
or we could have the same interface
and then improve
what's on the other side, the interface.
And then it turns out to be really better
because we're working on
active inference,
which is in a way
the theory about how the interfaces work.
And definitely in the act of inference
live, we're taking a different approach.
But it's like Mount Everest because
we're, you know, meeting at different
base camps together to talk with people
who have different perspectives.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is but that's where everything
thrives is in the intersections, right?
So that's yeah.
It's like, look how much stronger math is
when you hit it with philosophy.
Also vice versa or any of this stuff
or any of the bio, right?
Upgrade retrograde amnesia
to recommend a tower.
And it's like, whoa, you know?
So I think, I think
if nothing is lost in the intersection,
then what did you say earlier about
what Bucky called Emergence?
You said something for.
Emergence through emergency.
Yeah, it is emergency.
Like the every time, like survival or
like what. To actually connect.
That's what you said about your string
of natural language
being effortless in active inference.
We think about how the action
is following in some sense actually
on a geodesic a path of least resistance,
like the chemical reaction,
even if it releases a lot of heat
and light in the context that it's in,
it actually is the most probable thing
or the most energy releasing thing.
The free energy is negative
and so it dissipates and understanding
how that dissipation can be brought
into the informational regime
with semantic flow and like a Delta
G for semantic information
rather than just syntax or even chemistry
that's about this mapping of mappings
with free energy
as a nomadic concept in a way or a nexus.
So we connect the free energy
and the chemical.
We develop certain experiments,
maybe unique predictions.
And then by building the math, that's
general enough to interface nicely,
we actually we test the concepts
so that we can deal with the systems
that are more syntactic at the lower
level, going down into the quantum,
even more semantic at the higher level
into the teleological.
Mm hmm.
Good. Yeah.
And then the semantic
at the higher level. Right.
Then you can invoke homogeneity
type, chromatic type,
and then you can actually, you know,
all the types are nomadic as well.
So I like that, right?
Nothing is until it actually
like spreads.
So I also think it's
a false conception of movement.
If you actually think, you know,
if you don't start from the
middle and spread, you know.
Machine
it can we I wonder if we can anchor
some some some exploration
around one of your questions.
It's on the list. Yeah.
So like
but I don't remember what they are
and it might be too much
of a technical hassle to post them.
So if you could like pick one
of the questions that you're breaking up.
Yeah. Let me just share again
and then you tell me which one you like.
OK, ok.
Yeah.
This will be like the
Who Wants to be a Millionaire of.
Yeah, yeah. Right.
This is cool. Yeah.
Who Wants to be the Millionaire?
Back to that.
So we actually do a quick random number
generator.
Now pick one.
Yeah.
Just look at a few and then let's anchor
them and then go wild, whatever one.
OK, so, so actually
now this helps trip my memory.
So and then don't forget I have these two
so pick which one.
Maybe I can make it.
Can you see what I can?
I can
do to do.
Oh, I want to do.
I want to do well,
I want to do what is measurement.
I this is something
I've been tripping out on a bit
so and see so measurement.
Two to.
Yeah.
No I know where it is.
I thought I might pick a second one but
that's definitely should I go with that
and then you bring it on
or do you want to.
Go on sale
again.
See all the lovely places
we're saying what is the,
what is measurement right?
Yeah. Yeah,
you tell me.
Yeah. Well.
I tend to take
a lot of these I'm
finding that I have an attraction
to taking a lot of these questions
and putting them in some embodied form.
That seems to be
I don't know how I'm going to do that.
In a thesis in such a way
that I actually graduate. But
this is it's really interesting to me.
I you know, we have affordances,
we have tools and all these other things,
these kind of prosthetics
that allow us to make sense of the world.
But I really just think of them
as prosthetics.
In a sense.
We're we're making sense of the world
by feeling and
and I mean feeling in the one sense
of like feeling
whether or not
that actually relates to emotions.
That's
another really interesting question.
But you have to be conservative.
You know, I'm just talking
about feeling like our tactile sense.
And then we use all these affordances
to augment our technical sense
so it's really interesting
to think about like
all the subjective measurement
and science and whatnot
and how that's actually related to
to our embodied
like it won't be true to us at some level
unless we can make two out of it,
make sense out of it
and an embodied level.
So that's that, that's is
there is another kind of hook I had in
philosophy, but I can't really remember
what it is right now,
but that's something that's alive for me.
So I don't know if you have any thoughts
about it. Mm hmm.
Yeah. Well,
I'm like super empath, too, right?
So to, you know, I'm going to dissociate
the emotional from the irrational, like,
I don't believe in that.
And they both. Are equally.
They're right.
The rationality is like
the emotional guidance system.
So yeah, when I say like when I say,
what is a measurement?
I'm just saying there's a line
that goes into that that says, you know,
this is the fixed speed of light
and this is the this.
And so measurement seems like it only
holds up to a certain condition, right?
This is the this is the speed of light
until I change your ambient space, right?
If you lived on a Taurus
or if you lived on a fine bottle,
if you lived on something else,
I promise
you you'd have a different speed of light
because that's
just the illumination problem
in mathematics,
given a strange space right now,
I put a point source in it.
What if you trace out
all the rays, right?
Well, every point in the actual shape
be hit.
Not really.
It won't if you have
a very complicated space.
So for for me, how far
how far does the measurement hold?
And metrics again, since I'm
such a fan of like topology and sheaves
and things like this, the metric
seems like it is not substantial, right?
It is.
It is based on, like I said,
intersubjective agreement among agents.
So when you say,
you know, like,
yeah, I'm not sure if your question is
like is it objective or subject
I think all measurements here
are subjective, right?
And so also there's an actual problem
in the measurement if you're like strict
Copenhagen and stuff like that, right?
So nothing should, quote, exist, right?
If everything is in its free
form of superposition,
what does it actually mean
to measure something
without actually limiting the thing
and who is the measurement for
if you crush the superposition
into like one state?
I've measured it, right?
I don't know what that means.
And I also think that the minute
all your observers go away, that
the thing that was measured
goes back into its original state.
So that's why I said, like,
what is a measurement?
And Chris and I are always talking
about this right that that assumes
that you are somehow independent
of the thing that you're measuring.
And I don't know how to actually do
that. Right.
I don't really know what a boundary is
because if you zoom in to your arm,
we could take like an electron
transmission microscope
and I'd be able to zoom into your arm
in like 2 seconds.
So where the boundary go, you know,
where is the boundary
and that I'm I'm very perplexed
because the boundary in mathematics
is like some kind of asymptote, right?
What is an mass like?
You know, so are you dealing with
sort of a asymptotes?
And that's that's
what we're calling a measurement.
You're like a bus is this long true.
Until I subject the bus to a lot of time
or I for gasoline
on the bus and burn it,
you know what I mean?
So how long does the measurement hold?
You know
yeah I would that so so you're yeah.
So I hadn't thought so much about context
and feeling.
I was definitely like it's a fixed thing.
So that's that's useful to think about.
Not really like fixed according to him.
Fixed for that second but like,
everything is in freefall.
And like, you see,
I really think there is nothing
periodic here.
I think there is no repetition. Right.
We have to actually account for like
what, leap year or something, right?
Because the calendar is off.
So I'm really I'm really impressed that
in our like in everybody's free fall
and you know what?
The Earth is going
a thousand miles an hour east, right?
And if everything is rotating,
your own cells are popping in and out.
Where is the measurement?
I'm not sure nothing is fixed.
So it's very silly
to think that I have this measurement.
It's like if you only knew
that you were actually
working over discrete time
and that moment,
the moment that you were measuring
the buzz is no longer there.
Right?
So that's
what I'm very, very interested in.
I measured the bus 5 minutes ago,
but is it the same bus? No.
And I don't know what that means.
So that's like,
what are you actually measuring?
We can measure
proficiently many copies of the thing,
but you need to say that the measurement
is of the reflection of the thing.
And that's that's the one thing I do like
about the temporal parts work
is that the bus yesterday
is it really the bus today?
I don't know.
And I've always been
I've always been perplexed that,
you know, you wake up to the same space.
But do you really? I'm not really sure.
And so that's, you know,
boundaries.
I'm really interested in boundaries
and like how they actually.
How they work.
It's not really sure they do it quickly.
Like I can hit my hand on a on the glass,
but that's just that's at this scale.
Right.
If I so I'm just saying
that a measurement
if you're going to say a measurement,
then you need to be real precise.
I mean, there's no time involved.
There's no
this involved. It's only at an instant.
So this measurement holds at an instant.
Because tomorrow, who knows?
And what's up with the measuring stick?
Like there's so many
like quantum mechanically that either
sick doesn't exist anyway.
So so I don't even know how to use
all these friggin philosophical labels,
but I want to ask if your ambition
in, in trying to apply
to topology as kind of a paradigm
is to arrive at some form of realism
or are you interested in
I mean, I'm kind of wondering what your
ground is in terms of like,
yeah, what would be the
what's the end goal in terms of like what
would be the perfect math in your mind?
Like where would it take you right.
Yeah. Well, I'm after those grand
unified theories, right?
So I'm after the I'm after the unifying
the grand unified theories of physics
with the grand unified theories of math
because I actually think
the math one encompasses the physics.
That's why you see me going, hey,
why don't we look at like a number
theoretic version of a black hole,
something like that.
Because I think that in the grand unified
theories of math, I'm big at everything
because I'm a super TEGMARK
like level four.
But you're going to
you're going to get everything.
You're going to get
you're going to average.
What are you going to get?
Oh, yeah.
Well, that's how I say
like, oh, well, are you calling reality
like just this little blip?
You got to remember that I believe in
like in consciousness, right?
So my goal is to actually partition
the brain, partition the consciousness
so that you can actually experience
everything at once again.
I don't believe in linear time
I don't think it goes linearly.
And I'm really baffled
why the brain only does that.
And I think it does not because I know
when you're freshly formed like
a baby, it's a
very it's such a beautiful being because,
you know, she's like a little portal.
I'm like, where did you come from?
You know, like the very act of birth
is something interesting
because it seems like it's something
that got through the interface, right?
Where did this little portal come from?
And I'm actually I'm not so interested
in the mechanics of the interface.
I'm interested
in breaking through the interface,
taking off the interface
and trying another one.
Because again,
I think the two fundamental numbers
and everything that you're subjected to
here and the laws of physics or whatever
are just purely interface space, which
I which I think as a mathematics concept,
it would be so rad if we were all able
to take off the interface
of this complexity of this of our current
complexity and go somewhere else.
I don't mean Milky Way,
I don't mean that.
I mean leave this interface
altogether of three type of three space
at one time
and go find a different module's space.
Right?
And that's
what I'm trying to do is I'm like,
Oh, if you could actually partition
consciousness, right?
Because it seems like I don't know
if you all had like general anesthesia
or like if you've ever fainted
or anything.
I have like a few times
just from like kind of intense things.
But I remember something remained.
It's like you might have wiped out
the consciousness
by a general anesthesia, right?
But you didn't take away the awareness.
And that's what I was very curious about,
that something was still there.
And so Don Hoffman and like me, it's
like I'm
actually interested
in what that space is, right?
The kind of talking sensory thing.
Like, I can see that as an apparatus,
but I'm interested in like the divinity
or whatever,
the infinity, not in a religious sense,
but like what actually transcends this,
because I don't think anything here is
like real at all, you know?
So when people say,
what's your baseline reality?
Well, it's not this.
I'm really always curious
to get in the dream space.
to, quote, sleep, because
when I'm asleep, who's asleep, you know,
your body is not asleep, right?
Because you would die.
So I'm really curious in the states
that are actually
I guess I could say like this, I'm
trying to take subjectivity
out of the interface
and put it in a different setting.
I'm going to have subjectivity limited by
just what the body can do
because there's a lot of pain.
A lot of pain keeps people in the body
when I think you could actually be like
somewhere else, you know?
So if you could take subjectivity
on its own exploration,
which is what I think
mathematics is really good about doing,
like if I can have, you know,
people like, oh, let's
think about similar like what if,
what if we were actually here?
And also,
you know, at a Cambridge Apostle meeting,
that baffles people because, you know,
you have this imagination, right?
We're able to talk and you're,
you know, I can say, oh, Sarah,
it let's imagine like we're in Hawaii
swimming with the sea turtles.
You can go there just like that.
What is that?
Why can you do that?
What is that imaginary space?
So I actually think we're actually
really gifted creatures.
And you have this beautiful tool
called the Imagination,
which has not been fortified.
So what I'm trying to do
is actually put the imagination
in its own little Hogwarts school, right?
Like when you're young,
you're able to do plays
and you're doing all this,
and then you go up and it's like taxes
and like they're up and it's like, no,
I actually think we're here
to be creative.
And you can see all the philosophers
that I like are vital.
Is right.
And so I think being is creation.
So you can see that I'm here, too.
I think we're here to create new theories
and to break through the interface.
Now, that I'm not saying
people go jump in front of busses.
That's not what I'm saying. Right?
I'm saying
it'd be cool to peek through it.
Just sort of like how a new baby arrives
I am perplexed at birth.
Nobody can explain it.
And you have no idea,
like how something broke through.
Yeah, the interface.
So we're, I'm after with that
you see, I'm using
very beautiful mathematics,
I think I think life is very sacred
and very beautiful and it should be
supported and and explained
by an equally sophisticated
mathematical structure.
So I don't really abide by this.
The simplest version is the best.
I don't know about that.
I actually think that what is
what is sophisticated philosophically,
it should be equally matched
in sophistication mathematically.
And then you get a synergy and a harmony
and actually then you can actually
explain a grand unified theory
because I really think,
you know, if
everything is a diamond,
which I really think it is
you know, there's a lot of
I think if this reality is like a modulus
space of diamonds, then I can just easily
jump to a new modular space.
It's not that difficult. You know,
I don't know if that sounds like
you're like, who is this little part?
Oh, yeah, I'm totally like an explorer.
I'd be like, Let's jump in the
consciousness bus and go look at stuff
because it's not just this.
It's not just
what is your awareness never leaves.
And it's awesome to kind of enter
that space, you know,
and actually like bring it here.
If you can actually
bring the consciousness space to here,
then you're actually more synesthetic,
I think, you know?
Yeah, because I don't know where one
scale ends in the brain seems to be,
you know, the hologram itself.
So when everything when
your central processor is a hologram,
it makes me really curious about what
this space is.
I definitely don't think the brain
is like this, you know, of course,
you don't want to get hit in the head,
obviously,
but it's freaky ability
to rewrite, right?
It's like a super hamming codes.
You've got like error
correcting code in the brain, obviously,
to keep the organism alive, you know,
but I think, you know, to come up with
like a,
you know, you know,
like the Zeta function is a black hole.
Like, that's cool.
So I'm just kind of trying to upgrade,
you know, find
what is the essence of things.
And it's like,
oh, is it math what is this? You know.
The essence.
I'll ask one question, which is,
you know, how would you imagine that
this insight or this set of upgrades
potentially being taught
to advanced or younger students
could change research or practice?
Because I noticed words like descent
condition, define ability,
decide ability, completeness, of course.
So where do the sort of everyday
usages of these terms come into play
with how we can rethink them
based upon a new level of mathematics?
Or rigor?
Oh, that's such a great question.
Yeah, I'm such an advocate
for like new models of pedagogy, right?
Because I think the way
mathematics is taught now is formal
and it makes everyone frightened.
It's like you're taught calculus
first before logic,
before topology, before any of it.
Right. And so it seems like
people are not using the Apostle book.
That should be the only book use
for calculus.
Yeah.
So if you actually,
if you taught category theory
straight from the bottom up,
imagine the beautiful connections
that would be able to be made
cross-disciplinary.
You can see that one of my main goals
is to get people to talk with each other,
get the mathematicians
to talk with the physicists,
to talk with the philosophers.
I think through category theory,
he would naturally embody
this synesthete thinking, which is what
I'm trying to be an advocate for
because there's people like nonlinear
thinkers like me that can be easily
shunned and didn't say, well,
she works at the intersection.
She's not serious about the one topic.
And I'm like,
But the one topic is a reflection
of the other topics
when everything is a diamond.
So for me, I see that if you were
introducing these beautiful words
like a decent condition and like
if you start from category theory,
which is so minimally constructed
and only and allows you to
and what you need
to build your own space, right?
You are you are able to build
I would say
you're able to to build in accordance
with your own idea
versus taking another idea and chiseling
it away and adding things artificial
The nice thing about category theory
is that these limits, everything is built
into the actual theory itself.
I'm not starting
with something and adding and then adding
and then adding and then taking away
and being like, well, is it analysis
or is it like this?
So you see there's
there's all these ways and like Peter's
just like reconstructing you know,
functional analysis
as commutative algebra.
That's super synesthete.
I guess what you're doing is like taking
what you thought
was a difference and you're actually
making it the same thing.
So I'm such an advocate for inclusivity
and welcoming so many trains of thought.
And if everyone was like, Oh, hey, no,
that looks like just a morph ism of this.
And this is like a more physical this,
it would actually aid research
because everybody would be working
together,
you know, like,
can you imagine like new antidotes?
And, you know, I'm like a mental health
advocate and because,
you know,
there's been a lot of stuff like,
I don't know, I'm sure everyone has that,
you know, elderly family members
go through
some horrible neurodegeneration.
And I am not satisfied with the way
that the brain is being modeled.
And I'm like, you know,
if you actually were using the morph isms
or the chromatic tower idea,
maybe it would be able to understand
what's actually going on in
somebody, you know,
and we'd be able to relate to them
empathically instead of just like this,
like clear cut medicinal thing.
Well, they'll never be good again.
They lost their memory.
Well, we can you know, I don't think
it's something that can be lost
let's just try to reconstruct
the Morph isms, you know,
so there's like there's so many things
that I'm after with this one is unifying
all these branches
that are working against each other.
It's like when the mathematicians
and the physicists
honestly work together, right?
If they can
and not everyone's egos in the way,
then the beauty that results,
you get these beautiful grand
unified theories because it's like
we're meant to be inclusive
and everybody to help each other.
And so everybody knows that, like,
you know, not an advocate
for these like standardized tests.
And I'm going to test
you and I'm better than you.
And like, I don't know why we test people
to be better than everybody.
We could actually be
working on things like that.
So I think it would completely
revolutionize pedagogy and it would offer
a future model of like what
a what a Hogwarts would look like.
Because then you're actually like, OK,
hey, we have the imagination as a gift.
It is a gift that you have this.
And so through what I'm trying
what I'm doing here, it's
like a very creative take at learning
mathematics and things like that.
So then you've actually
welcomed into mathematics
those underrepresented
who identify as creatives.
Now, I also teach at this art school
and I was like, Well,
I don't have the best math gifts.
And I'm like,
But look at your visuals skills.
And at a certain sense
they're almost the same, you know?
So I think there's a lot of beauty, like
it's like diamonds and things like this.
We're taught very early
or even to like a lot of people,
you know, if you can integrate this
into the research, then you would.
I just think there's beauty in everyone
working together.
I'm not a very
competitive person. You know.
So they
reminded me of how could you imagine
a way that
that art
could actually inform math
rather than the reverse?
Like not not just art, but like improv.
Improvization Improvizational
arts of somebody drawing just free form.
And if you could figure out a dynamic
mapping of like,
oh, you're actually talking about this,
this kind of logic
and you don't and you're drawing it,
but you're not you're not putting it to,
you know,
you don't even know that you need that.
But you mean that
that is actually kind of fascinating.
Look how beautiful that is.
Yeah, I just got accepted.
What you just said is,
you know, I'm an advocate for pedagogy
in the creative setting.
So I'll do I'll do experiments like that.
All the time, like their topic is
to design a four dimensional university.
I want a four dimensional university.
I want a gymnasium featuring
flying lessons right.
And I want a library.
And I want you to talk about a Dinkas
or Tinkers or James Gates
air correcting codes.
These students, right?
Have minimal mathematic skills,
but they are in there learning,
analysis, geometry and topology
to actually make a structure
that can hold flying lessons.
They're actually having
to teach themselves
a four dimensional coordinate grid.
That's not Euclidean.
This is not Euclidean at all.
It's differential geometry right?
It's bumpy.
And I said, you know,
because it's four dimensional
and they only have hyper volumes.
So how amazing that it's sort of like,
you know, for me, it's very sad
that it's only a super exclusive, like,
you know, like the Exeter Academy
that has this Harkness method.
So what I do is I take the Harkness
method and I speak it everywhere.
Right?
I teach it at Cal State,
I teach it here and all over the place.
And that method of showing of
of giving a consent synergistically
like that and showing, you know,
just giving minimal instruction,
they're learning that themselves.
And so it's like, you know,
so I'm interested in other people
who want to experiment like that.
You don't learn of chapter one.
This is a triangle,
you know, nobody learns like that
because the way that you actually learn
is to integrate so, you know,
why do students have so much problem,
so many problems solving work problems?
Because they've been taught
these subjects separately.
These subjects are not separate at all.
They should be taught,
integrated in a holistic manner.
And you're totally right.
They're the way to get
holistic manner, like easily
digestible is in a creative way.
I showed my students like a
this awesome computer programmer
solving a 40 Rubik's Cube.
I said, recreate that.
And they actually had it 04
dimension does this.
Oh, it's a test.
Oh, it has that many sides
so much easier than a very linear lesson.
This is a force space.
But there you know, I think I think
you know if you're an into it like me
and most math comes from this intuition
space need to honor that intuition
space and I I really think it's shun
so there's mathematicians like Ramanujan
and stuff like that who was saying
I don't know where this idea came from
it just came from this
and you know that can be really shunted
and so but
I think a lot of this visionary stuff
comes from
like a nonspecific space and oh my God,
I will nurture people's creative space.
Look, how many ideas come out
when you do some kind of like fun
icebreaker like that, right?
So any time I host a conference or
something, you know, I, you know, I'm
like you know, imagine we were, you know,
alligators, you know?
So I had people change the space.
If you change it.
Oh, you know, you had claws,
what would you do with these pods?
You know?
And so it's like
if you can kind of shake up,
you know, the real
and turn it into something
kind of imaginary,
I think the imagination is more real.
So for somebody like me, I'm privy to the
imaginary space because like this pen,
I think there was an idea of a pen
before the pen.
So the pen is OK, in my opinion,
but I still think the imaginary
space trumps everything, right?
You had to have the idea of the car,
and I want to have the idea of the thing.
So I put a lot of my efforts
into nurturing,
like students, imaginary space,
you know, so.
Oh, my God. Yeah. Infusing, like having.
You can teach math in a creative way.
And that's why I'm so excited
that there are these people like me.
You know, I write books and it's like,
oh, it's like, I'm going to write.
I'm going to write, you know,
I'm going to write a girl an indictment.
I'll write.
Like, my opening line is, like, my new
book is like, she slept in an hourglass.
Why not write?
So that's what you're doing anyway.
And it's like, oh, wait through glass.
What is that?
So I can actually give you a shape.
I can introduce the shapes
you creatively,
and then I can actually
tell you theorems about the shape but
I didn't start with the theorems, right?
I started with this rough, intuitive idea
that actually had a texture to it.
So people.
But what does it like to sleep
in an hourglass?
God, does it get eaten by the sand?
Am I the sand?
Is somebody turn me over?
What happens when the time runs out?
You know?
And so through people's own
introspection,
I get some really solid thinkers,
and that's what I'm after.
I'm not after people wrote
memorizing and like, wrote test tests
of course, are difficult.
Right.
But it's how many people
remember the material after it?
You know, how long I have one?
So memorizing through rote
is not what I'm into.
I'm into actually building
the inner space, inner space
of independent learners who can think
and who can cross reference.
Because again, I will just always say
that your strongest thinkers or thinkers
who can think along
all of those intersections, right?
If there is a problem
like the rover crashes.
Yeah.
You need your CSP
but you also need your physics people.
You need your math people.
And that's why, you know,
normally those research groups have that.
I don't know.
And then you may have
that to write in your labs
I bet you have people from all discipline
areas
working on the inference stuff, right?
Each species of every type of insect.
Well, our approach with active inference
lab is provide
the affordance
and the opportunity to co-design
and wherever people are at in learning
about active inference
or are curious about related topics
or wanting to apply it in some domain,
we just sort of meet in the middle
and work to use active inference
as a unifying topic and a bridge
because it
and that's really that's why you're here,
because we actually got to intersect
with active inference
coming to me, all these other ideas
and what you said about the book reminded
me of Bucky Fuller's Tetra Scroll,
which is about the Goldilocks
and the Three Bears,
but the four of them are a tetrahedron
and so it talks about how the tetrahedron
is the minimal system.
And there's all these tetrahedral jokes
that are embedded in.
So it's like learning
by doing and through stories
and through characters and by drama.
So all these creative dimensions
that allow us to actually
be generative within so-called alternate.
But today's alternate fashion
is tomorrow's, you know, out of date.
And then it just it's historical.
So how do we respect rigor
as well as this
very radically intersubjective
like you're talking about with agents
with different perspectives.
But then also we need local logics
that aren't just totally discordant,
because then when we're talking about
the systems that sustain us,
we need those to also persist.
So how do we how do we?
That was my question is
how do we unify the rigor and the sort
of almost transcend it, or at least
if not universal, something like that
with intersubjective definitions
on the mortal plane.
Right.
And you can actually see right in my talk
I didn't give you some kind of loose map,
very particular.
Right.
So I think I'm actually rather
gifted in that regard.
Probably why I got heart so quick
with all this stuff
is that I'm able to introduce
an idea in a creative way,
but I give you absolute rigor
so that you know it through and through.
Right?
But I give you enough
rigor to know that object.
But I also endow you with the creativity
to be able to intersect it
somewhere else else.
So we all say the mortal plane, right?
But you won't really be aware
when you pass away.
And you already could have you
can't prove that you exist anyway, right?
So I'm like, yes,
respect your life force.
Yeah.
But don't ever think
that you're not infinite
because there's no proof
that you aren't right?
So there's this structure, like
there is no structural causality.
You know, you go somewhere,
but you will never be aware of it.
And I all I always say
when people ask me that, how do we
how do we take your,
your lovely, your lovely,
you know,
kind of goodies from the higher plains
and like works with them here.
And I'm like, well,
the higher plains are here.
You're in them, right?
It's not like it's outside of you,
like you're born from the very universe.
It's all in you.
And it's sort of like I remember
when I was trying to say,
like, would you actually be aware
when you pass on what you want?
Right.
That's that that's strange.
That's very strange.
So it seems to be this, like, impasse
limiting thing
all the more to value
your imaginary space.
Like, I know when I'm trying to go
to sleep and I'm like, I'm like, I'm,
I'm going to actually be aware
when I actually go to sleep.
You're not right.
When you go to sleep, you just you wake
up, right?
You're never actually, like,
aware of the moment you go to sleep,
right?
And I'm like, oh, that's very strange.
What is this awareness phenomena? Right?
So yeah, there is the AI.
And so when people call it Mortal Planet,
I guess I call it the interface.
That's one possible interface.
But again, babies can reach through it.
And I also think there's other ways
of getting other interfaces.
Yeah. So how do you balance the rigor?
Is that well, I'm giving you some of the
taught mathematics on the planet.
Yeah.
So that rigor,
you have to be for your own integrity.
And as a pedagog and an intellectual,
of course you are
you're here to make the planet
better for everyone.
So you already you have an integrity
to do honor to your subject.
So to do honor to your subject,
you learn it perfectly.
Yeah.
But you can also know that there are
stories around you learn the rigor,
but you can also how you learn
the rigor could be creative.
And it doesn't have to be through
a very rote memorization, right?
A category as an object
where if you learn it
in a very beautiful way,
then I'm also going to honor that.
So that's what I mean
by like a creative setting.
I don't ever go, Oh yeah, here's
this like diamond thing and that's it.
No, it's actually very specific
but it's according to who
I'm talking to,
if it's like super, you know,
mathematicians are already
this level,
then I just start with that right if
I'm introducing it to undergrads, right?
I will start with an intuitive
and intuitive kind of,
I don't know, derivative of the thing and
then actually introduce them into that
because I want them to retain it.
I don't want them to shut down.
I don't want to invoke
their cortisol system.
Right?
So I'm really an advocate
for like metacognitive techniques.
So once I, I'm getting
a really good feel
about how people learn.
And so the minute you know how you think
somebody like me is super abstract
for me, the intersection of something
and I'll get it right, the way that you
balance rigor and creativity is to know
who the actual learner is yeah.
So who they are.
And it's almost like, I guess I would say
my pedagogy is like a harp
and I'm tuning a harp
because I myself am a harp.
So the way that you're going to actually
balance the rigor and the creativity
is for your own self to be harp like
so that I can tune to the actual student.
Oh, they're more of a creative.
I'll try it like this.
Oh, they're more of an engineer.
Well, I'll try and engineering.
I'll try a system way, right?
I just explain diamonds
to like a bunch of computer
science people
and I turned it into data structures.
So if I can align it with something
that they already know, for me,
I think that learning
is about having constellations
in your head
how many constellations do you have?
Can you actually link
everything together?
And so if I'm, if there's too much
like rigor
without you know,
without a creative setting,
I think I have, I will fail the people
that don't have the constellations yet.
A bunch of experts.
I could do that as well.
But, you know, I also
nobody knows
nobody knows the consciousness realm.
Nobody knows what this actually is.
And at least I'm open to saying that if
every theorem I come up with in my it's
just a theorem.
Some people think
they're absolutely right.
And I really don't agree with that
at all.
We have rough ideas
of what it means to do this and this,
but that's why I'm asking, like,
what actually
are the fundamental units of life?
You know, you can tell me
when the interface breaks,
but you can't tell me about awareness.
And like if I asked a neuropsych, like,
why can I not split the consciousness?
Right?
They would say, Well, you know,
I don't know
because I'm not talking about like talk
about partitioning the brain.
And you just have like two.
It's like, like you would say like
a split screen, like those old movies.
I'm not talking about that. Right?
I'm actually talking
about double experience. It's
double experience, triple experience,
but not just sensory, you know?
So I think I think the way that
you balance the rigor with the creativity
is to also have integrity
with yourself, integrity to the subject.
Anyone who
actually wants to learn
it wants to learn the specificities.
Right?
But what's
what if you don't have creativity,
you'll never be able
to go anywhere with the rigor I give you.
If you're just rigorous,
you're just going to be there.
But if I can instill in you creativity
and you're actually going to be able
to take the rigor and link it
and intersect it.
And again,
if so, it's all about like why you saying
your phenomenological like state?
I think we're here to create new things.
I think being is creation.
So if I can give you rigor, but
it can also hold your imaginary space,
then you'll be able to take that idea
like nobody else
that me would take diamonds and find
the consciousness, you know what I mean?
Right.
So we're getting close
to close to the end of the hour.
But as I mentioned,
I'm kind of curious
about, but what what started you in math?
Like, like how old you were?
Totally young.
Well, I was like, Hmm, you know, I,
I was like, what is this thing?
You know what I mean?
I would stare at mirrors, and I'm like,
that's really interesting.
And then
I was basically asking my parents, like,
why am I not falling through the floor?
You know,
because I, I got pretty early on that
all this stuff
sort of looked like it was made
out of the same thing.
And I'm like, why are they, like,
why am I not falling through the floor?
Like, what is holding all this together?
It's also very, very curious
as to why I woke up in the same thing.
I was like,
Why am I not a lobster tomorrow?
So there was some kind of stability here
that I was very perplexed by.
I'm also an avid reader,
and when you read,
there was like a voice in your head
reading. And I was like, Who's that
who is that?
When people are talking to themselves,
You know, I was also highly aware that
when you're sleeping, who was asleep?
Nobody was asleep.
If I was up remembering dreams
and things like this.
So it's very vivid.
I would have lots of connections
with like animals and,
you know, not like body sport,
but it was super, super empathic.
And I would visit, you know,
kind of divine places and they're like,
oh, this is exciting.
And so what I found is that you
know, avid reader,
so already had the literary space,
but I was like, What are these?
I always thought
that there was something else.
And so what I love about math, right?
Is that it was it was
this beautiful
language and a gift
that allowed me to actually think about
higher worlds,
you know, in a in a structured way.
And so I was like,
oh, well, this is an actual language.
And I thought that
there was something universal about it.
Right.
But there's not a lot of dialects
for math.
You know, and it made it really simple,
like, oh, you know, category theory.
Hey, I do, too.
Versus like,
I was teaching myself Mandarin and mine.
You know, I still have this California
kind of accent thing right?
It didn't work so well.
And so the dialects
can actually hurt language, but
mass seemed to be this, like,
universal way.
And I was like, oh, hey, maybe
we can all figure out what this thing is.
Again, math is not
it's like my version of math, you can see
is very philosophical, right?
So it's like also
my favorite writer was like,
you know, Alice in Wonderland and
I'm like, oh, through the looking glass.
Like, that's cool. And at the end, he's
doing all the syllogisms.
And I thought, hey, if you take, like,
no, awesome.
Like, oh, syllogisms,
I can just mess around with that
and I've just messed with causality,
you know, paradox and things like that.
So super avid reader getting my hands
on big philosophy, very young and also
staying open so to like to what
is because I could tell that time wasn't
linear and I was like, I need a subject
and I can actually figure all this out.
Like time. It's not linear. Like,
how can I do that?
And I know topology and special spaces
and stuff like, oh, it looks like that.
Yeah.
I would say
it made my synesthete like comfortable.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Yeah,
cool. Well,
I don't think I have anything else.
And we're getting curves
and so what do you think?
I would be remiss not to ask
how you thought
active inference plays into this or what
you thought about active inference.
Yeah. How about like that's
what you're saying, right?
How the interface is actually intersect
or just.
Right?
What, what comes to mind when you think
about active inference and cybernetics?
And control theory
and where some of this, like agent
in the niche goes from,
there's the analytical,
there's the philosophical, and then
not getting into the theology
of what's real, but just like
there's the agents, the model about how
the agent is operating in the niche.
So where is what is active inference?
Yeah, well, I guess from like,
you know, the way that you've defined it.
So again, I'm interested into, OK,
so here's like
I guess my, my knowledge of it, right?
So here's an agent with
I mean, I guess, right?
With a certain interface,
I quote, interact with you like whatever
that means.
And so in my opinion, the way that things
are interacting is through
how many Morph isms
they actually generate.
So it's actually categorical.
So I don't do this
sort of like analytical, like philosophy,
philosophical, because again,
I'm from this higher space.
So if you just if you look at active
inference, maybe through category theory,
now what's really happening,
it's like, oh, oh, interesting at
what at what instant does
my interaction with this
like opposite agent or whatever
throw me into a reflective subcategory
where I'm actually just interacting
with myself.
So I'm really interested in where
the interface theory can actually
meet topological localization
like I was talking about.
So I think
see, what I like about this is that it
sounds like
you're doing the same thing that I'm
doing with much different language.
So topological localization, right?
I'm interested in
how do you find the inverses and relate
more and make my space stronger
by passing
through these reflective subcategories.
And so if it's like, oh,
if the active inference is
how these agents are swapping
and actually interacting
because that's very curious.
It's very curious how what I'm taking
your information into my data structure
and I don't know like what
receiving looks like on that end.
So I would just say that categorically,
it sounds like we're doing the same thing
and then it gets pretty meta for me
when I'm sort of like I take your info
and then it becomes part of my system
and it's part of my own reflective
subcategory.
And I. Like, I don't.
Know, like keep moving on or something.
But if it's about,
if it's about how interfaces work,
I still don't know how you got
the original interface. So
I don't know if that or anything.
You know.
Some of these ideas
we talked a little bit about in
active inference, 17 to 0.1 and two
because that was the paper
that we focused on for those weeks
by Fields and Glazebrook.
But I think what you have pointed to
today really also
gives us a lot of things to go over again
and think about.
So maybe we can stay in touch
and if you ever want to join
for another conversation or participate
in any other way, it'd be awesome
because it's really thought provoking
and I hope our lab enjoys it.
Yeah, so fun.
Thank you so much. I had a great time.
Thank you. Whoops.
Bye. And.